janu i know usually you ask me questions
but can i ask you a question
sure what are jalapeno poppers oh i know
this one
okay they're deep fried jalapenos filled
with cheese
one time at a buffalo wild wings in
jacksonville the the nice one not the
one above the gas station
i ate 50 of them in two minutes everyone
at the hospital was so impressed
got it thanks janu you're welcome
why did you do that because you're the
only person here that's nice to me
okay
[Music]
hey janet hi there what are you watching
my greatest accomplishment ever i'm
trying to cheer myself up because i'm
sad
i think i might be in big trouble can
you bring me something that will make me
not sad
let me think
sorry that took so long here you go
oh dang are these from my favorite
restaurant stupid knicks wingdog
stupid knicks closed down because a
pelican fell in the flash fire
but he opened a new place called ugly
knicks meat trench
these are an exact replica of that
recipe
why are you so nice to me well
you were very nice to me while i was
rebooting also
i'm programmed to be nice to everyone
janet i just realized something
i love you okay
i have one more question for you hi
there
jason and i are getting married in 10
minutes and you're invited
i'd like to read a poem janet my digital
queen
janet we can dare to dream send nude
pics of your heart to me
jacksonville jaguars rule jason
when i was rebooted and i lost all my
knowledge i was
confused and disoriented but you were
always kind to me
and according to the central theme of
600 songs movies poems and novels that i
researched for these vows in the last
three seconds
that's what love's all about does
anybody here object to this marriage
of course we do how could we not have
checked overruled
i just want to make sure that i have
this right um giannio
is not a taiwanese monk but rather
someone named
jason mendoza a failed dj from
jacksonville florida
i wasn't a failed dj i was pretty
successful
and you two are married hell's yeah
homie
we love each other she makes the bass
drop
in my heart and jason is a person who
was near me
and then he asked me to marry him and
there is nothing in my protocol that
specifically barred that from happening
so i agreed love you too babe
janet please tell me how this could have
happened
unclear as you know each time i am
updated i accrue new knowledge and
abilities
my suspicion is that when i was rebooted
i bonded with jason in a way that i have
never bonded with anyone before
i seem to have gained a new
understanding of love i
also learned how to do this
i will speak to you later go to your
void okay
no jenna come back hi there go sure
thing
no stop doing that me go goodbye
jenna come back i love you i love you
too what you're saying
is there are certain aspects of your
existence here in the good place that
are confusing for you
and you're searching for someplace to go
where you feel less lonely
i know somewhere you could go
why did you do that because you weren't
nice to me
you're my friend okay
okay how would you feel about giving
jason and me couples therapy
i'd feel great
[Music]
janet what's happening unclear my guess
is i'm operating in a way i'm not
designed for and it's
creating a small glitch but if i'm
helping you guys i say
what has one thumb and wants to keep
going this not lady
eh incompatible with objective
truth janet the problem isn't me lying
to you but rather you lying to other
people like when you said to jason
i'd be happy to help you and tahani that
was a lie
that wasn't i'm always happy to help
people that's my main purpose
i know i know but it was still a lie
even though you didn't intend it to be
because you weren't actually happy to
help them
because you're in love with jason
say what now hi jason i love you
oh word word i've been
avoiding telling you my excuse was that
i needed time to
evaluate my complex feelings but that
was just a rationalization
this might be the last time i ever get
to talk to you so there it is
i love you and i hereby stop avoiding
this topic and
rationalizing it by saying the situation
is complicated
or that my brain is grinding like a fork
in a garbage disposal
all right whatever you're not really a
part of this chidi
hey guess what i think i love you too
girl
i'm not a girl i'm also not just a janet
anymore
i don't know what i am if i'm going to
the mall anyway i might as well pick
jason up some jean shorts
kind with the frayed edges where you can
see the pockets coming out the bottom
so that he can study better
sure tv play cartoons for jason
oh my janet has a crush on you
i'm sorry it's not just a crush
i think in one of the reboots you and
janet were
married whoa married oh
this flat screen must have been a
wedding present
it's all starting to make sense now is
is this a good time to talk
well there's no time like the present
and here there's neither no time
nor the present go ahead
so you know how me and you used to be
married when i was dead before
i think i'm starting to catch feelings
again for you
and if i don't double die in this ihop
and the
judge lady doesn't turn you into a
marble
do you want to try being boyfriend
girlfriend i'm not a girl
but yes i'd very much like to go on a
date with you somewhere sometime
as opposed to here which is nowhere at
all the times
you get it yeah hi janet it's me
jason your boyfriend i
really miss you i know we were in a
fight before
but i hope you've forgiven me because
i love you girl
not a girl
you can sit on that bench as long as you
want whenever you're ready you just walk
through
[Music]
i love you janet i love you too jason
i hope you have a nice rest of eternity
i made you something
ah dip i lost it it's okay no it's not i
made you this cool thing so you remember
me even when you're married aquaman
and i lost it somewhere in this forest
it's a magical squirrel probably ate it
jason it's okay
i'm never gonna forget you in fact to me
you won't even really be gone
i don't experience time the same way you
do
i kind of live all times at once
i know what you mean once i smoked
salvia and saw the past in the future at
the same time i try to brush my teeth
with my cat
to me remembering moments with you
is the same as living in them
can you just remember the happy times
and forget the bad stuff
there was no bad stuff it was
all good
[Music]
oh dude you're back jason
yeah what but how why
funny story remember how i made you
something
and i thought i lost it because it
wasn't in my pocket turns out it was in
my other pocket
by the time i found it you were gone i
was just gonna leave it for you but i
was worried it would get eaten by that
magic squirrel
so i decided to wait for you to come
back every so often a different janet
came but
i knew it wasn't you jason it's been
like a thousand
beramies i know but i wanted to see you
again
it was actually pretty easy to wait i
sort of just
sat quietly and let my mind drift away
thought about you and the infinity of
the universe
kind of like a monk what do you mean
[Music]
looks good not a girl
chidi wait up
you